-Nathan,
thank you for being here.
Thank you for spending your
night off from Broadway
to be with us.
-It is my pleasure.
You're my favorite.
I'm gonna say it out loud.
You're my
favorite talk-show host.
-That is so kind of you to say.
-And I think it's because
I didn't go to college,
and you're like
the frat bro I never had.
-Oh, thank you.
-I look at you and I think,
"We're gonna have fun.
We're gonna do Jell-O shots.
We're gonna chat up
some fine ladies.
We're gonna make a night of it.
-Oh, my God.
And we haven't done that once.
Well, now I also aspire to that.
-Oh, me too.
I'm sorry I was a little late.
My security clearance
at Rockefeller Center
was downgraded.
-Oh, no.
-Yeah, so, technically,
I'm not even a guest tonight.
I'm now an NBC page.
-Oh, no.
-So, I can
answer your questions,
but I will have to
get back to my tour group.
And they say I'm not topical.
You know, seriously,
I'm beginning to worry for
Jared Kushner, 'cause he's
way too pretty for prison.
-Oh, yeah. He's very handsome.
Very handsome.
-Well, for
The White House, yeah.
-Wait. Are you saying there's
a lower bar The White House?
-I think so.
-Okay.
-It starts right at the top.
-I want to ask about the Oscars.
They were presented last night.
-Yeah, don't tell me who won.
I DVR'ed it.
And don't tell
me Best Sound Mixing
or I'll be very upset.
Yes, I did see it.
Apparently, due to
the recent controversy,
no one wanted to
talk to Ryan Seacrest,
which means
nothing changed there.
But...when I heard
that a woman accused him
of sexual harassment,
my first thought was, "A woman?
Boy, do I owe
some people a lot of money."
The nice thing was --
the "In Memoriam" segment
included all the staffers let go
by the Trump administration.
-Yes, it was nice.
-And I was very happy that
Best Animated Short
went to Kevin Hart.
And...
[ Applause ]
But everybody's favorite movie
is "Black Panther."
-Yeah.
-I loved "Black Panther."
-Oh, you did?
-Oh, "Black Panther," which,
coincidentally,
is the name of Betty White's
"personal device."
[ Laughter ]
Have I -- Or perhaps...
Perhaps I've said too much.
I read it in Parade magazine.
-It was not in Parade magazine.
-So, look, here's
the problem with the Oscars.
I hate to point out the obvious,
but there's so many award shows,
by the time you get to it,
it's anti-climatic.
-It is.
-The week before, I saw the
AARP Movies For Grownups Awards.
The category was
Best Performance by
a Leading Actor
with a Hip Replacement.
-Oh, no.
-Best Supporting Actor
in an Adult Diaper.
[ Both laugh ]
It's got to be stopped!
-Now, you mentioned the --
A lot of stories broken about
the terrible behavior of men
in Hollywood over the years.
-Yes. Yes.
-How do you feel about
the current state of Hollywood?
Are you feeling optimistic?
-Well, no. No.
I think everyone's just
frightened right now.
And I hope
it will grow and become
a real understanding
between men and women.
But, recently,
you know, Disney --
It's happening at Disney.
-Yeah.
-A Disney executive
was accused of
making lewd comments
to his employees.
But I did some research, and
things at Disney --
Sexual harassment --
it goes way back.
-Oh, it does?
-Oh, yeah.
In the old days, Mickey Mouse
got quite handsy with Minnie.
-Oh, no.
-Oh, yeah.
He used to brag about
his sexual prowess.
[ High-pitched ]
"I'm big, really big."
It was in the police reports.
-Oh, you've read
the police report?
-Donald Duck was accused
of indecent exposure to Daisy.
-Uh-huh.
-Although, he only wears
half a sailor suit.
He's pretty much
exposed to everybody.
-Yeah, that's true.
-And, saddest of all,
beloved Goofy was once found
in a Los Angeles hotel room
with the Three Little Pigs.
There was a lot of
huffin' and puffin' going on.
Yeah. You know, the original
slogan for Disneyland was
"the horniest place on Earth."
-No.
-Yeah.
-They changed it, though.
-But they changed it.
-They changed it.
That's for the best.
Thank goodness.
-Yeah, thank goodness.